all righty folks i'm here to review
spiderman no way home i'll give you all
my thoughts in just one moment first
this video is sponsored by our friends
at expressvpn
[Music]
alrighty so let me start with this it's
a great movie it's really really good so
good so i know usually you're here to
hear me destroy a movie and wreck it
with facts and logic there'll be a
little bit of that at the end because i
have some questions but let me just say
overall super enjoyable film so let me
begin with what is clearly the best part
of this movie and that is that there are
three separate character arcs that are
brought to an excellent terminus you
have the new spider-man the tom holland
spider-man and the big problem i've had
throughout with the tom holland
spider-man you can see my review of the
preview of spider-man no way home is
that it had no weight there was no
gravitas to the series at all it was
really cotton candy kind of floss and i
don't like comic book movies like that i
want my my characters to have some
weight i want some bad stuff to happen
to them i don't really want it to just
be like a cw movie i always felt like
the tom holland spider-man movies were
more cw than they were dc they didn't
take themselves seriously they were
always kind of wink wink not not
and i understand that spider-man's
character that he's supposed to be jokey
and friendly neighborhood spider-man and
all of that but the original toby
mcguire series the first couple of
movies at least actually had some weight
to them
in this new series of tom holland they
didn't have a lot of weight this time
they're actually given some weight to
the point where when again and this will
be filled with spoilers spoiler alert to
the point when aunt may dies what i was
thinking in the theater they're not
gonna kill her are they because again
that would not be in keeping with sort
of the mood heretofore in the tom
holland spider-verse the ant-may
character is is a jokey character like
she has a few kind of profound things to
say but it wasn't like uncle ben there's
been no tragedy in tom holland
spider-man's life except for the death
of iron man and then when they show the
green goblin essentially hitting her
with his flying machine and she goes
flying i thought to myself okay well she
should die from that i think they expect
the audience to think okay no one dies
in this universe and then when she dies
oh that's that's effective when she dies
and she utters the uncle ben lines ah
okay so that's kind of what we were
waiting for for tom holland's spider-man
to turn from a spider boy into a
spider-man you need some actual tragedy
in his life and so the maturation of tom
holland spider-man from high school kid
to young man with actual
responsibilities is pretty great so i
really enjoyed that character arc and
then the fact that they were able to end
the character arcs for both the toby
maguire spider-man as well as for the
andrew garfield spider-man i thought was
pretty fantastic as well obviously the
big problem for for toby mcguire is that
he had never really been able to save
all these people he was really close to
including the williams foe green goblin
norman osborne womanful by the way turns
into great performance in this william
defoe remains a really underrated actor
because he's so weird-looking so people
tend to think of will default as the
weird-looking guy who makes weird faces
but in this movie when he is playing
sincere norman osborne who's trying to
fix people he's great and then when he
plays green goblin he's wearing goblin
he is a terrific actor and the tobey
maguire attempt to fix norman osborn to
even lay down his own life to save
norman osborne is really well done and
the idea of him is sort of the older
guide for the other two spider-men is
really quite good they love me andrew
garfield of course is the the most
emotionally scarred spider-man because
gwen stacy died in his arms and he's
able to save the zendaya mj here by
jumping down and catching her in his
arms as opposed to attempting to to grab
her with the the web which is how gwen
stacey is i thought that was terrific as
well and the scenes between the three of
them are the best thing in the film
first of all they did all the things
that you want from this film i said even
in my preview of the preview i said that
if they don't have the meme where all
three spider-man are pointing at each
other i don't even know what the purpose
of this movie is and they did they did
that entire meme they have an entire
scene where somebody says peter parker
and all three of them start pointing at
each other and it's really really funny
you have an entire scene making
reference to the fact that toby mcguire
had a back injury very famously during
the original spider-man series which led
to contract negotiations and all of this
and so you have him his back being
cracked by by andrew garfield you have
the fact that andrew garfield his brand
was the amazing spider-man and he
doesn't believe he's amazing so they all
have to call him amazing i should call
you the amazing spiderman now this sort
of winking and nodding normally i don't
like when i talked about the the new
matrix movie i really really didn't like
it specifically because i hated that
aspect of the film but that's because it
was being aware of what the audience
thought of the film and it was making
references outside of the universe to
what the audience thought of the film
here's the thing about feelings they're
so much easier to control than facts my
brand that's not what was happening here
all of it was supposed to exist inside
this universe and all the lines that
they're saying could exist inside that
universe so i really appreciated the
sort of hat tips and shout outs and the
ironic kind of throwaway lines about you
know andrew garfield saying yeah i
fought this this russian guy who used to
dress up like a rhinoceros which is a
reference to paul giamatti at the very
end of the second andrew garfield film
the reference to jamie foxx falling into
the vat of electric eels and toby
maguire being like yep that'll do it all
that kind of stuff just works it really
does work and the interplay between the
three different characters is really
pretty terrific because you have tom
holland who has lost aunt may and who is
now having to deal with the fallout from
that and he's got the two older mentors
who both have had losses are helping to
guide him you have andrew garfield who's
totally insecure which is not a problem
shared by either toby maguire or by tom
holland spider-man and they're both able
to guide him and then you have the
younger spider-man who are able to
provide this this sort of moment of
teaching for toby maguire which is what
he really needs to do in order to move
on with his life so i thought all of
that stuff was just first rate like the
last half of the movie is pretty
spotless we'll get some more on
spider-man no way home in just one
moment first do you know what big tech
and big government have in common they
both would like to monitor you and then
maybe silence you depending on what your
opinions are as somebody who deeply
cares about their right to privacy
online i mean i am a political person
i'm constantly searching for material
for the purposes of my show that i'm
sure would raise red flags with the
government that's none of the
government's business same thing when it
comes to hackers none of their business
this is why i use expressvpn the problem
with bigtech they can search for what
you do online and track it what you're
searching for the videos you watch
everything you click they can match your
activity to your true identity using
your device's unique ip address when i
use expressvpn however they cannot see
my ip address at all my identity is
anonymized by a secure vpn server plus
expressvpn encrypts 100 of my internet
data for protection from hackers and
eavesdroppers expressvpn is by far the
best vpn i've tried it's the vpn rated
number one by business insider and
countless other tech publications it is
super simple to use you tap one button
and now you are protected watch this i
take out my phone i go to expressvpn
it's not connected oh no so i hit the
button now i'm connected it was that
simple and now i'm protected defend your
right to privacy protect yourself at
expressvpn.com
ben yt that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
benyt to get three months for free visit
expressvpn.com
ben yt to learn more
everything from the point where all of
the villains start arriving to the end
of the movie is really spotless which
brings me to my big problem with the
movie i told you it was coming and that
is the opener the opener makes no sense
i miss the part where that's my problem
okay so tom holland going to dr strange
and saying i want you to erase
everybody's memory except for these
specific people and then doctor strange
trying to do it and quasi failing now
all of that it cuts very much against
the grain of who doctor strange is
supposed to be he's not somebody who's
like you know i'm going to change the
fabric of the universe just for the
funsies of it it's sort of out of
character it's him more adopting the
robert downey jr role after the death of
iron man which is obviously what they're
going for there that feels weird but
i'll allow it into the spider verse they
do this much better because into the
spider verse it's the villain who opens
the multiverse into the spider verse
it's kingpin and he says i want to open
the multiverse so i can get back to my
wife and kid who died in a car accident
and i want to bring them into this
universe like all of that makes perfect
sense and then it's the job of
spider-man to to close those universes
that makes sense doctor strange opening
the universe doesn't make a lot of sense
to begin with and so the first half hour
of the film because of that is a little
bit slow and a little bit
odd but you can't do this to me and
let's be frank about this the the kind
of happy ending that tom holland is
given here with regard to saving all
these people again i understand that
it's instrumental to the plot
but doctor strange is correct and all
these people are villains who have
killed at this point probably thousands
of people
and somehow tom holland with science can
heal him first of all if tom holland is
this amazing at science let me just say
he really needs to go into psychiatry
because there are a lot of people who
have deep and abiding mental problems
who seem like they could be solved but
like can schizophrenia be really solved
by like this green goo that you just
inject in somebody because if so i feel
like you should get on a patent for that
forthwith and immediately and make that
available to wide swaths of the american
population with that said everybody's
great in it obviously you know bringing
back all of the old villains is great
because it brings some of the weight
from the old franchises back the doc ock
character arc is pretty great because
alfred molina is terrific butterfingers
again william defoe is excellent in this
and was the heart of the of the original
tobey maguire series i respect that
still the best villain in the canon i
still think better than doc and then you
have kind of the throwaways of jamie
foxx and you have sandman and all this
where do all these guys come from it
plays on nostalgia without really
killing the nostalgia and this is the
mistake that the star wars and new
movies made the star wars new movies
they brought back all the old characters
and then they proceeded to murder them
in the worst possible ways cannibalizing
them in favor of the new series the new
spider-man film doesn't do that instead
it really does pay tribute to the old
films and gives those characters
something new to do that actually fixes
their place in the franchise and that's
really what i think is worthwhile about
it plus the ending for tom holland which
is that he has to learn that he can't
get everything the way that he wants it
because the first two movies he really
does that's a great character arc for
him obviously i don't think that we've
seen the end of him with mj we haven't
seen the end of him with ned but the
fact that he is willing to allow them to
live their lives because he believes
okay maybe they'll be happier if they're
free of the stigma of spider-man is a
good thing one other critique i'm not
sure how much longer hollywood can keep
trotting out the premise that every
villain is alex jones because i mean
they literally make jay jonah jameson
alex jones in alex jones's studio
hawking alex jones supplements i'm not
sure how much longer that's going to
play and not make it bizarrely
time-bound i will eat your so this
movie's a massive box office smash and
what that means is that coming out of
covet there is a market for movie
theaters for sure now i do think it's
gonna be a lot of blockbusters i don't
think people are gonna go back to
theaters to watch the last duel gonna
cry movies are basically gonna become
and it was headed in this direction even
before covet just the big spectaculars
but that market still does exist people
do want to see this in a crowd and
people do want to see it on the big
screen for sure
here is my overall rating second best
spider-man film
of all time after into the spider-verse
followed by spider-man
1 and then spider-man 2. i'm gonna put
some dirt in your eye alrighty if you
like reviews like this smash that like
button and leave us a review below we'll
see you here next time
pizza time